[Music]
or is there a possibility of doing a
duet with Taylor Swift this Sunday
listen I love for the peace to end I'd
love to take it off the barbecue Kate
just posted a celeb cameo pack trailer
for her swish swish music video some see
it as a response to Taylor's bad blood
but talking today with Sirius XM's the
morning mashup Katy made it seem like a
VM a duet with Taylor is unlikely I mean
I'm down she also wouldn't give much
about her relationship status with ex
Orlando Bloom it's nice to keep people
that you love around you when you get
older lines get blurred as for who could
be joining her on Idol Charlie puth
Lionel Richie Luke Bryan and Keith Urban
have all been rumoured to be in the mix
but what about this blast from the past
nobody's David Hasselhoff killed it in
guardians of galaxy vol 2 and was a hit
judging AGT today ET confirmed he is
interested David Hasselhoff will be
joining you at the judge's table I've
not heard that actually okay I know that
there's some people that are in play and
David's not necessarily been one of them
bless well Idol alum and former guest
judge Adam Lambert may won in at Project
Angel Food 2017 angel Awards Gala we
asked him about returning to item 7 they
reached out to you is it something you'd
be interested in they haven't reached
out to me I love the show I think it's
great I would love to come back and pop
in
[Music]